less than half of young people are proud
to be English in one in ten is
embarrassed now we've never been
outspoken in our patriotism we don't
share France or America's idealistic
view of their national identity and we
are aware of the dangers of the sort of
nationalism we see from Putin in Russia
or a divan in Turkey in fact we were so
shy that for many years the only people
who would proudly brandish the st.
George's flag were those on the far
right and for we minorities growing up
in England the flag struck terror in our
hearts is a symbol of neo-nazi violence
fortunately those days are over the flag
has been reappropriation but clearly if
I can get it out but clearly many people
particularly the young are still
squeamish about being English I don't
think that matters what could be more
English than such self-deprecation but
my message to the one in 10 who are
embarrassed of our country is the
following before you take your privilege
for granted have a chat to the refugees
who gave up everything risking their
lives to come here and if they don't
remind you anything that redeems our
country
then nothing will Rachel well there is
an old phrase in there to be born
English is to win first prize in the
lottery of life and it's interesting
that all the latest polling shows that
the English are actually least proud
about being English then the Scots are
about being scotch or the Welsh or about
being Welsh or the Irish are about being
Irish and this you know when you go
abroad and you meet another English
person you don't cleave to them in the
same way that as a as a Scot might I
found it fascinating because I did this
debate on my LBC show and English people
ringing up and explaining why pride is
it doesn't make sense to be proud to be
English because of course it's the pride
being English is not an achievement they
said we were just we are we were born
here we didn't do anything to happen to
be born here we should be proud of our
achievements but the only few people
that rang up and did say that they were
proud to be English were asylum seekers
and Afghanistan méxico rang and spoke to
me at length about why he found himself
expressing pride in having become
British in getting the British of course
passport and living in England
why he was proud to be English and and
he was so thankful and grateful to his
country and that's what led me to think
okay
I'm not going to demand that we all
express pride in being English but
certainly to be embarrassed to be
English I think is a step too far
I think where if it makes sense I think
we're quietly proud of not being proud
if that makes sense I really found a
fantastic quote from Bill Bryson who
said what an enigma Britain will seem to
historians when they look back on the
second half of the 20th century here's a
country that fought and won a noble war
dismantled a mighty empire and a
generally benign an enlightened way
created a farce a welfare state in short
didn't ally everything right and spent
the rest of the century looking on
itself as a chronic failure and he says
to achieve so much in people who haven't
achieved enough is what I love about it
and I think that's true and you know
that report you're referred to refer to
it talks about young people not feeling
patriotic I think it's a a bizarre
concept for a young person I think maybe
you have to have lived a bit longer to
have seen and experienced what your
country does and the way it handles
things before you might become patriotic
but I think if you have I think if you
said to young people ask them individual
questions like you know stuff about the
fact we live in a democratic country is
the fact that we would champion freedom
of speech if you had stuff about back
there they would call what they feel
about that product if when we go to you
Greg before you go to and continue a
second we just have a look at the fact
that this varies actually by region from
region to region if you look at for
example Lincolnshire in the Midlands
ninety percent of those areas identify
as strongly English whereas London
Oxford and Cambridge only 32 to 45
percent of people in those areas
identified strongly English and if you
ask the question who is proud to be
English 72% of those who responded yes
were over 65 whereas only 45% of 18 to
24 year olds are responded with a yes
and 49 percent believe England's best
years are over 17 percent thinks they
are still to come
Greg but both of you muddled up England
and British what you said both of you
use the words British use that you can
required a British yeah but that seems
to me the issue is are we British or are
we English yeah we don't you can see why
fear to Scotland
go to Wales you can get no less so I'll
put no variableness there the the
identity is partly with the self but you
can see why they are so you know I'm
Scott you know you find words I don't
think England has the same identity your
point there was about more regional yeah
identity I think he's right I mean I
think you know you're these figures show
you're more proud to be a Geordie than
you are to be English no I think that
those figures were saying that those
from those regions are more proud to be
English than the southerners yes so like
66 percent of people in whole for
example are proud to be English but to
your point I had a very you said that
when you go on the holiday you'll see
the Scots coming together but you won't
see the English and I've just I got back
today actually from Benidorm lost you
got I lost my glasses
yes whilst I was there but my point was
that actually I had a very different
experience you know the the English were
very much coming together you know
whether it was in the bars together
whether it was in the sports access cuz
you're on the Costa del Sol though no
but what I'm saying is it was very much
John State weiming there sure English
like that I'm English I've got a bit
more banter proper than that but we
don't help ourselves so like we don't
have sent George's there for example as
a bank holiday I dragged you then we
should and we should actually be proud
of ourselves I think one of the problems
is the st. George's flag and I tell you
we were petrified of this yeah I mean
that became that became a confusion
between nationalism patriotism and the
emblem of that confusion was this in
George's flag and also of a certain type
of Englishness and when Emily Thornbury
went in 2014 she went down to the Essex
by-election of Rochester and strewed and
she tweeted a picture of a kind of a
white van in a driveway and ass in
George's flag draped windows and said
sort of Rochester scene or something
like that on the tweet she was regarded
as very snobby because what we're also
talking about is this sort of sense that
you know Metropolitan Londoners think of
themselves as cosmopolitan they're not
necessarily very English
and there we'd had this woman from this
labor shadow Tony general going to
leaving Islington and going out into the
sort of provinces where white man van
lives truven she what she what it's
essentially that expressed to me I'm not
going to bring in brexit but the brexit
vote wasn't really a vote against Europe
against London and sort of London
Metropolitan to your point about the
flag nicked Orion painting bolsa that we
can add placed your intro to says we've
allowed the idea of Englishness
practically to be seized partly seized
by the far-right and also to become
associated with the idea of a race white
anglo-saxon rather than a nation which
of course has many races and many faiths
yeah I'm constantly told that by the way
so when I had this - again when I had
this debate in my LEC show I was told by
some callers that imagine you can be
British but you can't be English because
actually you're not white and I said I
think you're mixing up anglo-saxon white
anglo-saxon with with a nationality with
a country England is after all a country
but there is still this debate even
within minority communities who prefer
to call themselves a British Pakistani
over English for the same reason I think
it's partly because of the history if
you go back to the last year what's the
66 World Cup final game what's the type
of it and what's interesting is the flag
that was used there was not that one it
was the Union Jack yeah you never see
the Union jet like you see the treacle
or in patterns all over France or you
see the the Stars and Stripes all over
America we don't find a flag here but in
America it's quite people are quite
happy to be Italian Americans or German
Americans they're quite happy to say
look I'm a man first of all an American
but I'm of German descent on one Italian
flag you can never disrespect the flag I
think that the Royal Wedding we've got
an image here from the from the Royal
Wedding and it shows that actually it
did wonders for the reviving the Union
Jack and also I think the Scots have
always historically been quite proud to
wave their own flag
I suppose much more nationalistic oh
yeah we've also kind of escaped the
worst of nationalism I think I'm gonna
ask you guys alright so if I were to ask
you what is your least and and most
favourite thing about England
- queuing week you all the time and we
don't ask questions we stand there like
dummies in a cubes
and yeah that's about the thing I hate
about England we just have these manners
which which I don't think should be
employed in that situation the 20 of you
and nobody says why were you standing in
this view what's your favorite thing say
something good I love I loved cueing I
know I hate you and I hate I think it's
the worst thing about I love I love the
things I mentioned before the free
speech the democracy I love individual
things like our literature I love our
music our achievements quickly went
wrong sure
I hate cueing I was in acutal two
o'clock this morning at border controls
I'm with you on that
I like the seasons yeah I really like
the changing weather away back Greg I
like the humor yes and which I if you go
through this list the top one I like the
tolerance I like that actually this is
quite a tolerant society that adapts to
change yeah
I'm very proud of our fantastic British
press and also our great cup of tea and
you can never ever get a good cup of tea
Yorkshire zor-el so yeah